new this morning no doubt you've heard
the term the great resignation
but where are people going and what are
they doing for work good question
changing careers not easy a lot of folks
are doing it now there's one industry
that is booming in spite of the pandemic
it's cosmetology our heather mills with
a look now at the las vegas beauty
industry
dry erase boards charts lectures
everything you'd expect in a classroom
but this is no ordinary class these men
and women are here for hands-on training
many swapping nine to five for
flexibility and creativity this is my
passion to do hair linda armagesque left
a career as a research assistant i've
been thinking about this for a while i
want to do something for myself she
enrolled at the cosmetology institute of
las vegas and she's not alone before the
pandemic
2019 we did about 51 students last year
we enrolled 269 students owner denise
dixon says her school has a 97 percent
graduation rate and she thinks there's a
couple reasons why enrollment quadrupled
a lot of people were facing layoffs at
the height of the pandemic and so people
are now just looking for that backup
plan even though beauty shops had to
shut down for a brief time dixon says
cosmetologists got creative because
clients still want to look their best
the need for it never went away for
instance nail technologists they started
making press-on nails and making money
that way
hair stylists were making wigs you know
so they were still able to make some
sort of income even though they couldn't
work with the public hands-on another
benefit moms like arm adjust say
cosmetology gives them more of a
work-life balance i can do this on my
terms work as much or as little as you
want whether it's hair skin care or
nails it's the industry that continues
to grow every year and for anyone
looking to swap careers arma just says
don't be afraid it's a beautiful journey
you will enjoy it heather mills live
local now
it takes about 1600 hours to complete
the full program
just shy of a year if you attend full
time and they also offer discounted
salon services for the public which
enables the students to further their
experience so i would assume as long as
our hair and nails keep growing the
industry
need will keep growing as well yeah
hopefully and i think it's you know it's
wonderful that they have those uh
mannequins there with the wigs and stuff
like that but i think they do prefer
worrying about working on people i i'm
pretty sure they do and it's nice to get
a discounted services exactly but you
know it's interesting a lot of folks
during the depths of the pandemic when
everyone a lot of people lost their jobs
now that the workforce has come back a
lot of them are looking at different
opportunities they're going into real
estate they're driving for uber they're
opening their own business whatever the
case may be or going into cosmetology
maybe they're looking for a different
field if they have the opportunity i
always felt like we were we're always
meant to to do more than just one thing
in life people have lots of talents so
maybe it's the time to explore by now
if the boss is watching that doesn't
necessarily mean now is the time for us
to explore our
talents i appreciate that thank you